WILL SHOW YOU THE LATEST BIDEN
BLUNDERS.
HE’S HAVING TROUBLE WITH THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
ALL HAD.
FIRST LET’S START WITH A BRIEF
HANNITY HISTORY LESSON IN THAT
NORMS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
SURROUNDINGS APPOINTMENTS.
TOP DEMOCRATS WANT YOU TO
BELIEVE IT WOULD BE IMPROPER FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO NOMINATE
ANYONE TO REPLACE
JUSTICE GINSBURG DURING A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION YEAR.
THAT IS A COMPLETE, TOTAL LION
FABRICATION.
HERE ARE THE FACTS.
WE WILL LAY IT OUT STRAIGHT UP,
NEWS YOU CAN USE THAT THE MEDIA
MOB WON’T WANT YOU TO SEE.
ARTICLE TWO, SECTION TWO OF OUR
CONSTITUTION IS CLEAR THAT THE
PRESIDENT SHALL APPOINT
AMBASSADORS, OTHER PUBLIC
MINISTERS AND TREASURES OF THE
SUPREME COURT AND ALL OTHER
OFFICES OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE U.S. SENATE’S ROLE IS TO
ADVISE AND CONSENT.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE, SENATORS
VOTE WHETHER TO CONFIRM THE
PRESIDENT’S NOMINEE.
NO EXCEPTION WHATSOEVER IN THE
CONSTITUTION FOR ELECTION YEARS.
SINCE OUR COUNTRY’S FOUNDING,
HERE ARE THE FACTS.
THERE HAVE BEEN 29 VACANCIES AT
THE U.S. SUPREME COURT DURING A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION YEAR.
29.
29 TIMES BEFORE, A SITTING U.S.
PRESIDENT HAS NOMINATED A
REPLACEMENT IN AN ELECTION YEAR.
WELL, 19 OF THOSE TIMES WITH THE
SAME PARTY AS THE WHITE HOUSE
CONTROLLED THE HOUSE AND SENATE.
IN THE CASE OF THE PRESIDENT AND
THE SENATE ALIGNING, 17 OUT OF
THOSE 19 JUDGES WERE CONFIRMED
AND AN ELECTION YEAR.
WHEN THE PRESIDENCY AND THE
SENATE ARE CONTROLLED BY
OPPOSING PARTIES, THERE’S BEEN
TEN EXAMPLES OF THAT.
WELL, ONLY 1 OUT OF 10 GOT
CONFIRMED BEFORE THE ELECTION.
TWO WERE CONFIRMED AFTER THE
ELECTION WHEN THE PRESIDENT’S
PARTY WON THE ELECTION.
SIMPLE FACTS.
DULY ELECTED CONSERVATIVES, THEY
PREFER TO APPLY WHAT WE CALL
ORIGINALISTS OR
CONSTITUTIONALISTS.
LIBERAL DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTS,
THEY LIKE TO APPOINT JUDICIAL
ACTIVISTS, THINGS THEY WILL
NEVER GET DONE AT THE BALLOT BOX
OR LEGISLATIVELY.
THE LAST TIME HE SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE WAS APPROVED BY AN
OPPOSING PARTY DURING AN
ELECTION YEAR BEFORE THE
ELECTION WAS IN 19 -- I’M SORRY,
1888.
THAT’S WHEN THEN-PRESIDENT
GROVER CLEVELAND GOT TO MANAMA T
NOMINEES APPROVED.
132 YEARS AGO.
HE DIDN’T STOP DEMOCRATS IN 2016
FROM DEMANDING THAT THE
REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED SENATE,
AGAIN, THE OTHER PARTY, VOTE TO
CONFIRM JUDGE MERRICK GARLAND.
OBAMA’S P PICK TO REPLACE THE LA
JUSTICE SCALIA.
WATCH.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE A
FULLY STAFFED SUPREME COURT OF
NINE.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT NOMINATES
AND THE SENATE ADVISES AND
CONSENTS OR NOT.
BUT THEY GO FORWARD WITH THE
PROCESS.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE EXPECT
THE PRESIDENT’S NOMINEE TO BE
GIVEN A FAIR HEARING AND A
TIMELY VOTE IN THE SENATE.
THE SENATE SHOULD DO THEIR JOB.
EVERY DAY GOES BY WITHOUT A
NINTH JUSTICE IS ANOTHER DAY
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE’S BUSINESS
IS NOT GETTING DONE.
>> WHEN THE CONSTITUTION IS 100%
CLEAR, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS THE RIGHT TO
NOMINATE SOMEONE TO BE A JUSTICE
OF THE SUPREME COURT.
THE SENATE’S FUNCTION IS TO HOLD
HEARINGS AND DEVOTE.
>> Sean: REPUBLICANS CONTROL
THE SENATE.
MERRICK GARLAND WAS NEVER
CONFIRMED, AS PRESIDENT OBAMA
ONCE FAMOUSLY STATED ACTUALLY
MANY TIMES SAID ELECTIONS HAVE
CONSEQUENCES.
THAT INCLUDES THE REPUBLICAN
SENATE MAJORITY.
THEY CAN COME BUT THEY’RE IN THE
BACK.
IN 2016 THE AMERICAN PEOPLE PUT
DONALD TRUMP IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
IN 2018 THE G.O.P. INCREASED ITS
MAJORITY IN THE U.S. SENATE.
DULY ELECTED REPUBLICAN
SENATORS, LET US BE CLEAR AS THE
CONSTITUTION PRESCRIBES, THE
PRESIDENT WILL NOMINATE.
THE SENATE WILL ADVISE AND
CONSENT.
THE CURRENT HYSTERIA SURROUNDING
PRESIDENT IS LAUGHABLE.
DEMOCRATS, THEY DON’T GIVE A RIP
ABOUT PRECEDENT.
DEMOCRATS COULD HAVE
FILIBUSTERED A JUDICIAL
APPOINTMENT.
UNDER GEORGE W. BUSH, GUESS
WHAT, DEMOCRATIC SENATORS, THEY
BROKE CENTURIES OF PRECEDENT.
THEY BEGAN FILIBUSTERING
JUDICIAL NOMINEES WITH
REGULARITY.
THE DEMOCRATS DID THAT.
2003, AN ATTORNEY YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER HIS NAME, MIGUEL
ESTRADA, FIRST EVER COURT OF
APPEALS NOMINEE TO BE
SUCCESSFULLY FILIBUSTERED.
HE WASN’T THE LAST.
HARRY REID AND COMPANY, WELL,
NUMEROUS CHARGES WERE BLOCKED BY
THE DEMOCRATS USING THE
FILIBUSTER WHICH HAD NOT BEEN
USED PRIOR TO THAT.
GUESS WHAT.
IN 2013, OBAMA’S PRESIDENT, HIS
FELLOW DEMOCRAT, THEN SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER HARRY READ,
HE BROKE PRECEDENT ONCE AGAIN,
NOT THE REPUBLICANS, THE
DEMOCRATS.
HE TRIGGER THE SO-CALLED NUCLEAR
OPTION WHICH ELIMINATED
FILIBUSTERS FOR JUDICIAL
NOMINEES.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY WOULD NEED
CLOTURE.
THEY WOULD NEED A SIMPLE
MAJORITY.
DEMOCRATS DID THIS.
THEY DID IT IN PARTS OF
HARRY REID COULD LOAD THE
ALL-IMPORTANT D.C. CIRCUIT COURT
OF APPEALS WITH LIBERAL
NOMINEES.
THEY HAVE STACKED THE COURT IN
THE PAST.
SO NOW AS THEY ARE THREATENING
TO DO SO WITH THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT, WITH JUST 43 DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION, BELIEVE
THEY WILL DO IT WITH THE
SUPREME COURT.
THEY MEAN WHAT THEY SAY.
TONIGHT IF DEMOCRATS ARE UPSET,
THEY HAVE NOBODY BUT THEMSELVES
TO BLAME.
MAINMAYMAKE NO MISTAKE.
THEY ARE THROWING A COLLECTIVE
MAJOR POLITICAL TEMPER TANTRUM
AS ALL THEIR FRIENDS IN THE MOB
AND THE MEDIA LIKE THIS FORMER
FAKE NEWS CNN HOST HAVING VOWED
TO BURN THE COUNTRY TO THE
GROUND.
JEFFREY TOOBIN, SO-CALLED LEGAL
EXPERT.
PROBABLY ONE OF THE DUMBEST
LAWYERS IN THE COUNTRY CALLING
FOR UNREST IN THE STREETS.
OTHERS LIKE OBAMA WINGMEN ERIC
HOLDER, WHEN THEY GO LOW, WE
KICK THEM.
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR ED MARKEY.
THEY ARE CALLING FOR THE
DEMOCRATS TO PACK AND STACK THE
SUPREME COURT.
ADD AS MANY LIBERAL JUSTICES AS
THEY CAN.
MORE DEMOCRATS ARE THREATENING
TO END THE FILIBUSTER ALTOGETHER
MEANING NOW ON LEGISLATION WHICH
HAS NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE,
THAT’S NEVER HAPPENED.
SOME ARE VOWING REVENGE BY
ADDING WASHINGTON, D.C.,
PUERTO RICO, AS NEW STATES.
WHY?
THEY FIGURE IT WILL BE FOUR MORE
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS TO GUARANTEE
THEM A DEMOCRATIC SENATE IN
PERPETUITY.
AS CHUCKIE SCHUMER IS NOW
THREATENING AND PELOSI
THREATENING, NOTHING THEY ARE
SAYING IS OFF THE TABLE.
THEY ARE THREATENING THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY TO UPEND EVERY PRECEDENT
WE HAVE EVER HAD.
THEY ARE THE ONLY ONES WHO’VE
DONE IT IN THE PAST.
THEY OPENED THE DOOR AND THIS IS
WHAT THEY ARE THREATENING NOW.
>> WE MUST ALSO COMMIT TO USING
EVERY PROCEDURAL TOOL AVAILABLE
TO US TO ENSURE THAT WE BUY
OURSELVES THE TIME NECESSARY.
>> ONCE WE WIN THE MAJORITY, GOD
WILLING, EVERY THING IS ON THE
TABLE.
>> IF, IN FACT, THEY ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN PLACING A JUSTICE
ON THE COURT, I THINK WHAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO DO, ASSUMING
BIDEN’S PRESIDENT AND THERE’S A
SENATE MAJORITY FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT COURT REFORM.
AT A MINIMUM AS PART OF THAT
REFORM PACKAGE, I THINK
ADDITIONAL JUSTICES NEED TO BE
PLACED ON THE SUPREME COURT.
>> Sean: YOU’VE GOT TO
REMEMBER NOT ONE DEMOCRAT EVER
SPOKE OUT ABOUT HILLARY’S OH,
DELETED SUBPOENA EMAILS AND
LEACH PIT AND HAMMERS.
THEY NEVER ONCE COMPLAINED ABOUT
HER DIRTY, EVEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" FINALLY
CALLED IT RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
DOSSIER THAT BECAME THE
FOUNDATION OF ILLEGAL WARRANTS,
PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON THE FISA
COURT.
THEY IGNORED ALL OF IT.
KEEP IN MIND COURT PACKING ISN’T
UNETHICAL PROCESS THAT WOULD
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF JUSTICES.
LET’S BRING IT FROM NINE TO 13.
THERE BY GIVING A SITTING
PRESIDENT AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTROL THE COURT.
IT’S A PRACTICE THAT IS SO
CONTROVERSIAL, SO CORRUPT, THEY
SAY THEY ARE HONORING
JUSTICE GINSBURG.
SHE WAS AGAINST IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> NINE SEEMS TO BE A GOOD
NUMBER AND IT’S BEEN THAT WAY
FOR A LONG TIME.
I HAVE HEARD THAT THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF JUDGES.
I THINK THAT WAS A BAD IDEA WHEN
PRESIDENT FRANKLIN DELANO
ROOSEVELT TRIED TO PACK THE
COURT.
>> Sean: TODAY THE EXTREME FAR
LEFT SOCIALIST RADICAL
DEMOCRATIC PARTY CLEARLY DOESN’T
AGREE.
IN FACT, YOU HEARD THE, WELL,
REAL SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
CONGRESSWOMAN O’CASEY CORTEZ
SAYING THAT IT SHOULD RADICALIZE
ALL DEMOCRATS.
SPEAKER IN NAME ONLY
NANCY PELOSI SEEMINGLY
THREATENED TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT, IMPEACH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AS A TACTIC TO
STALL THE SUPREME COURT
NOMINATION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU IN THE HOUSE COULD MOVE
TO IMPEACH PRESIDENT TRUMP OR
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR AS A WAY
OF STALLING AND PREVENTING THE
SENATE FROM ACTING ON THIS
NOMINATION.
>> WE HAVE OUR OPTIONS.
WE HAVE ARROWS IN OUR QUIVER
THAT I’M NOT ABOUT TO DISCUSS
RIGHT NOW.
SPEAKER TO BE CLEAR, YOU’RE NOT
TAKING ANY ARROWS OUT OF YOUR
QUIVER.
YOU’RE NOT TAKING ANYTHING OUT.
>> GOOD MORNING, SUNDAY MORNING.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY.
WE TAKE AN OATH TO PROTECT AND
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: ARROWS IN THE QUIVER,
WOW, OKAY, HERE WE GO.
NANCY PELOSI KIND OF
MALFUNCTIONS LIVE ON CAMERA.
THE DEMOCRATIC STRATEGY IS CLEAR
AND PRACTICAL AND DANGEROUS.
DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA MOB, THEIR
STATE RUN TV ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
THEIR ALLIES ALL OVER, THEY WANT
TO UP AND OUR ENTIRE SYSTEM OF
PRECEDENT, THE ENTIRE THING.
THEY ARE THROWING A MASSIVE
TEMPER TANTRUM, SMEARING
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEY WILL
VILIFY ANY NOMINEE.
THIS IS A COMMON PRACTICE FOR
DEMOCRATS.
IT’S ACTUALLY A TERM.
WE CALL IT BORKING AFTERWARD
SENATE DEMOCRATS DID TO
JUDGE ROBERT BORK.
BASELESS SMEAR CAMPAIGNS
CONDUCTED AGAINST JUSTICE
CLARENCE THOMAS.
WE WATCH THE REPULSIVE
STATEMENTS AND ACTIONS RECENTLY
WITH JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
NO MATTER WHO THE PRESIDENT
NOMINATES, NO MATTER WHO IS
QUALIFIED OR HOW QUALIFIED OR
HOW REPUTABLE HE OR SHE
APPARENTLY A SHE WILL BE,
DEMOCRATS WILL WAGE SMEAR,
SLANDER BESMIRCHING CAMPAIGN THE
LIKES OF WHICH THIS COUNTRY IS
NEVER SEEN.
WHAT DO THEY CARE?
THEY’VE ONLY DRAG THE COUNTRY
THROUGH THE MUD FOR FOUR YEARS.